das hier ist kein gemälde das ist ein
transfer wir neben dem inhalt eines
bildes und kombinieren ihn mit dem stil
eines anderen
das ganze funktioniert mit texturen
und mit gemeldet wir benutzen dafür
neuronale netze eine form von
künstlicher intelligenz und style
dancers gerade nur eine art und weise
wie die kunstwelt verändert herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video auf
doktor watson
[Musik]
kunst etwas das nur wir menschen
erschaffen können ein kreativer prozess
der auf wahrnehmung vorstellung und
intuition fußt kunst soll menschen eine
neue perspektive zeigen der gesellschaft
einen spiegel vorhalten und inspirieren
eine maschine die nur zahlen berechnet
kann so etwas doch nicht verstehen oder
nun schauen wir doch einfach mal style
transform das beispiel aus dem intro ist
zwar schön aber zugegebenermaßen auch
nicht mehr als ein filter der inhalt
bleibt derselbe nur der stil wird
verändert und in den meisten fällen
verwendet man als vorlage für diesen
stil sogar ein kunstwerk eines
menschlichen künstlers wie kenny hat
sich also keine wirklich kreative
entscheidung getroffen
anders sieht das schon beim arzt brüder
aus das experiment von german
funktioniert im browser und kann zwei
bilder miteinander fusionieren
die ergebnisse sind manchmal
faszinierend und manchmal verstörend
aber in jedem falle eins neuartig noch
besser wird es bei generatoren wie
dispersionen dass nordex ist auf dieser
website findet man gesichter von
menschen die es nicht gibt eine
künstliche intelligenz hat sich die
gesichter ausgedacht und das ziemlich
überzeugend manchmal mit brille manchmal
mit bart
übrigens habe ich euch alle katy tools
die man selber ausprobieren kann unten
in der video beschreibung verlinkt
darunter auch das hier den dieb dream
generator
denn wenn künstliche intelligenzen
anfangen zu träumen
dann wird es richtig spannend diesen die
dream stil kennen wir wahrscheinlich
schon ziemlich tricky und wird aber es
ist einer der ersten originellen ki
stile den mann als solchen erkennen kann
die tri mart ist ein begriff was ihr
vielleicht noch nicht kennt sind die
vielen tausend anderen spiele die auf
ähnliche weise erzeugt werden aber oft
ganz anders aussehen
[Musik]
das hier sind die bilder vom künstler
mario klinger mann den ich in münchen
interviewen durfte das faszinierende am
arbeiten mit neuronalen netzen ist dass
die mehr im gegensatz zu der klassischen
zum klassischen ansatz der generativen
kunst wo ich jetzt programm schreibe
bestimmte regeln aufstelle und dieses
programm sich innerhalb der regeln in
einem spiel raum bewegen kann
bei neuronalen netzen ich im grunde
genommen nicht mehr programmierer
sondern eher wie ein fotograf mich in
einem raum den ich selbst geschaffen
habe bewege und dann interessante
locations örtlichkeiten suche und dann
mir eben die ausschnitte wähle
die ich dann interessant finde oder die
ich besonders finde mario klinger man
sieht sich selber also weniger als
künstler der den pinsel schwingt sondern
eher als entdecker er bewegt sich durch
die welten der mit seinen programmen
selber geschaffen hat und sucht nach
neuartigen dingen die er spannend findet
nach dem gespräch mit mario habe ich mir
viele fragen gestellt wenn mario auf
entdeckungstour geht und sich die besten
bilder heraus sucht heißt das dann dass
er selber gar nicht der künstler ist
sondern eher der kurator
wem gehören die bilder wenn sie doch
durch zufall entstanden sind und
überhaupt was ist eigentlich kunst weil
ich ein generell eine faule person bin
zitiere ich hier einfach mal wikipedia
im engeren sinne werden damit ergebnis
gezielter menschlicher tätigkeit benannt
die nicht eindeutig durch funktionen
festgelegt sind
aha es muss also von einem menschen
gemacht worden seien damit dass kunst
wird direkt danach steht aber dass hier
der formations prozess des kunstbegriffs
unterliegt permanent einem wandel der
sich entlang von dynamischen diskursen
praktiken und institutionellen instanzen
entfaltet man könnte argumentieren dass
genau das gerade passiert eine neue
praktik die arbeit mit künstlicher
intelligenz verändert den kunstbegriff
im oktober 2018 wurde zum beispiel das
mit k erstellte gemälde le monde bel ami
in new york für stolze 432.000 dollar
versteigert ti ist hier definitiv
angekommen
man könnte aber auch argumentieren dass
künstliche intelligenz nur das werkzeug
der menschlichen künstler ist sie ist
etwas in direkter als ein pinsel würde
aber ohne menschliches zutun gar nichts
erzeugen
mario klinger man muss immer noch den
programmcode schreiben sich gedanken
machen und stellt seine besten werke aus
er ist der künstler
und ich finde sogar dass die werke genau
die anstöße geben die kunst für viele
ausmacht sie inspirieren geben menschen
eine neue perspektive und alten der
gesellschaft einen spiegel vor
harry verändert gerade die gesellschaft
in so vielen bereichen dass es manchmal
schwierig ist bei allem mit zu kommen
dass nur noch etwas vermeintlich
inhärent menschliches die kunst mit
hilfe von perry geschaffen wird
verdeutlicht diesen wandel und zeigt
auch dass keine branche davon verschont
wird
40 prozent aller jobs könnten in den
nächsten 15 jahren durch automatisierung
verloren gehen
vielleicht sind sogar künstler davon
betroffen um das zu testen haben wir in
den letzten tagen ein neuronales netz
mit 40 doktor watson videos gefüttert
und das dazu gebracht ein komplett neues
oktober zehn videos zu schreiben und das
hier ist das ergebnis ich habe in diesem
video angekündigt dass ich meine meinung
über wissenschaft und technologie ein
wenig ändern werde
neulich sagte ich meinem roboter dass
ich nach frankreich ziehen würde
er sagte dass frankreich das gleiche
problem hatte wie deutschland es gibt
keine aktiven vulkane und es gibt keine
brunnen er hatte recht zumindest an
manchen stellen weigert sich
wissenschaftler die auswirkungen von
anthropogenen faktoren auf die umwelt zu
untersuchen
vielleicht bin ich meinen job doch nicht
jetzt sofort los gott sei dank
aber es gibt schon einige coole tools
die uns hier in der kreativbranche recht
unter die arme greifen
mit dem content aware fill in vfx
programmen können wir zum beispiel ganze
autos verschwinden lassen
das funktioniert mit künstlicher
intelligenz und auch wenn die funktion
nicht immer ein perfektes ergebnis
liefert macht sie mit wenigen klicks
etwas möglich was vor drei jahren noch
aufwändiger handarbeit und vor 20 jahren
beinahe unmöglich gewesen wäre mit einem
facebook erzielen manche user im
internet bereits bessere ergebnisse als
hunderte profis die mühsam ein gesicht
re kreiert haben und netflix hat die
ersten zwei staffeln von house of cards
gestellt weil ein computer programm die
daten der netflix zuschauer analysiert
hat und die kombination aus kevin spacey
david fincher und politthriller
besonders erfolgversprechend war nicht
mal ein drehbuchautor eine gute idee
hatte
inzwischen müssen wir nicht mal mehr
musik produzieren das was ihr das ganze
video über im hintergrund gehört hat
sind songs die mit hilfe von künstlicher
intelligenz erstellt wurden
im musikwettbewerb beats und spitz vom
wissenschaftsjahr konnten künstler ihre
ks songs einreichen und vor kurzem
startete das publikumsvoting unter dem
link in der video beschreibung könnt ihr
euch alle eingereichten songs anhören
und abstimmen welche ihr am besten
findet okay heute und auch in den
nächsten jahren wird kann noch keine
abend füllen dem kino filme oder
computerspiele mit bewegender story
generieren
aber was wir heute schon sehen hören und
selber ausprobieren können zeigt uns die
richtung in die es gehen wird
wie ist eigentlich bei allen bereichen
die durch künstliche intelligenz
verändert werden ist ist er eine
unterstützung ein werkzeug das den
menschen helfen soll
vielleicht erledigt sie nervige arbeit
hilft bei der wahl des themas oder sie
kreiert sogar neue bilder aber der
kreative prozess wird immer noch von
einem menschen besteuert die spannende
frage für die zukunft ist ob irgendwann
einmal etwas wirklich neuartiges
kreieren kann das mit konventionen
bricht aktuell lernt sie das was sie
gefüttert wurde und kreiert
dementsprechend auch nur werke in diesem
rahmen aber die größten künstler aller
zeiten waren eben nicht die die den
perfekten durchschnitt getroffen haben
sie haben neue dinge gewagt regeln
gebrochen und polarisiert so etwas zu
berechnen wird nicht leicht deswegen
jemand eine frage an euch
hättet ihr ein problem damit wenn eure
unterhaltung komplett von einer karte
stammt könnten ihr an einem berechneten
film spaß haben und sind die gefühle die
uns ein ki gemälde vermittelt falsch
weil die ki diese gefühle wie selber
gespürt hat schreibt mir eure meinung
dazu gerne unten in die kommentare ich
bin sehr gespannt was sie zu diesem
thema zu sagen haben
das hier ist das vierte und letzte video
von mir im wissenschaftsjahr 2009 10
künstliche intelligenz wenn ihr hier
oben klickt dann kommt ihr zu einer
playlist mit einem teil videos von mir
darunter die frage ob gut oder böse ist
wie selbstfahrender autos funktionieren
und wie kann die medizin verändert
vielen dank an die gemeinnützige
organisationen wissenschaft im dialog
und an das bundesministerium für bildung
und forschung für die unterstützung bei
diesem video
vielen dank an euch fürs zuschauen und
wie immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]